Yo, it's your boy back in the place
to be. Livestreaming,
bringing the heat. Can't you see? Got something
special, something brand new, a guest and a
project just for you. Give it up for
Avital,
a mastermind
dropping knowledge, the future you'll find. He's brought
Cipher Netties.
It's the name changing the game. Ain't nothing
the same. Kubernetes
complex and deep, but Cypher query secrets they
keep. Unlock the power, simplify the task. Avital's
here, answers to ask. So grab your headphones,
get ready to vibe this live stream's fire.
We're taking your lives. Tech talking insights flowing
like a stream. Let's dive in deep to
Cypher Netty's dream.
Yo, it's your boy back in the place
to be. Livestreaming,
bringing the heat. Can't you see? Got something
special, something brand new, a guest and a
project just for you. Give it up for
Avi To, a mastermind
dropping knowledge, the future you'll find. He's brought
Cipher Netty.
It's the name changing the game ain't nothing
the same. Kubernetes
complex and deep, but Cypher query secrets they
keep. Unlock the power, simplify the task. Avital's
here, answer to ask. Go grab your headphones,
get ready to vibe.
So grab your headphones, get ready to vibe.
This livestream's
fire. We're taking you live. Tech talking insights
flowing like a stream. Let's dive in deep.
The Syphonetti's
dream.
To the Rawkode Academy. I'm your host, David
Flanagan, also known across the Internet as Rawkode.
And this is an episode of Rawkode Live
where we take a look at some of
the coolest and most interesting Kubernetes and cloud
native adjacent projects we can find. And today
is no exception.
We're taking a look at a new way
to work with Kubernetes and query Kubernetes using
a new
Cypher based language.
So
let's meet.
Sorry. There's something in my ear there. Let's
jump over and meet our guest for today.
Hello, Avital. How's it going, man? Hey, David.
How are you? Thanks for being good, man.
This was
of the coolest things I heard in a
while.
Yeah. I mean, I'm always absolutely astounded at
just how good AI music generation has gotten
these days and being able to put together,
you know, just a couple of minutes of
personalization
to thank the guests for coming on. You
know? It's it's just so nice. And Even
pronounce my name right. You know? Well, I
I more than yeah. That took a lot
of work. Like, you have to go out
and change. I couldn't just write Avital. I
had to phonetically do it. But same with
Cypher Netties and Kubernetes. I'm getting quite good
at just predicting how to get it to
say the right thing though. But, yeah. Four
e's. Yeah. Yeah.
But it's it's a pleasure to have you
join us today, and we're gonna be taking
a look at a project called Cypher Netties
that enables a new way to interact with
Kubernetes clusters. I could not be more excited
to take a look and show people how
this all works. However,
let's meet you first. Could you please take
a moment to introduce yourself and tell the
audience who you are? Yeah. So my name
is Avital.
I've been doing this for a while. I
started working with computers
when I was a young kid. I taught
myself programming when I was six. I got
my first computer and taught myself BASIC. I
think there was BASIC installed on the MS
DOS.
And
so I've pretty much been doing that since.
When I was 20,
I actually made it
big with my high school band. So I
had a semi successful career as a professional
musician during my twenties
and,
kind of from there, I kind of shifted
towards,
doing a career in the industry,
mostly
revolving around infrastructure.
I did some stuff with backend, front end
work, some full stack,
but
ultimately gravitated toward infra,
since container technology and Kubernetes started becoming a
thing, found myself really drawn into it. And
so this has been like the focus of
my career for the past ten years or
so.
Awesome. Thank you for sharing. I mean, I'm
now really curious about what type of music
you were playing in your band and what
instrument you played, you know? Well, my my
I got my face tattooed, so you can
probably guess that he was on the heavier
side of things.
Hey. Always a pleasure to have a fellow
metalhead on things, know, because
I could set and place some soil work
at the start of all these episodes. That'd
be a very happy man, but I don't
think the audience would appreciate it too much.
So
conversation for KubeCon, perhaps. Maybe we can do
that over a beer. However Sounds good. Today,
we're keeping things
geeky, techy, and Kubernetes.
That is a terrible I'm never saying that
again. There we go. Said that.
Could you tell us I wanna get into
the history of CipherNetties, but let's just start
with what is it?
Right. So,
so Cypher Netties is
what it sounds like. It's Cypher for Kubernetes
and Cypher,
for those of you who don't know what
Cypher is, is the
language from Neo4j,
which is one of the, I guess, pioneering
graph databases
that put graph technology in the center.
And
Cypher evolved over time into the GQL
standard,
which is like
being a franc of graph databases now,
but
Cypher,
the originals flavor of Cypher was the first
graph oriented query language that I came across.
And I remember this first interaction with Neo4j
and what Cypher does really cool is that
you use
ASCII art, I guess, to draw these patterns
using
parentheses and arrows,
and you draw these patterns that you want
to match on a graph
and get back or act on, like do
these CRUD operations on
instances in the graph that match the pattern,
the ASCII pattern that you drew.
This immediately,
like I fell in love with it immediately
because it turns all these joins
like joins that you express in SQL are
just expressed by a little arrow
in Cypher.
And it was, to me, it was, you
know, it was whimsical and
like creative
and fun,
even just one of those things that brings
a lot of fun into computing, you know?
And as I got more and more into
doing infra work, it always kept nagging me
that Cypher would be such a great language
for infrastructure because a lot of what we
do
when we communicate with each other and we're
doing design sessions on whiteboards is drawing like
node graphs, right? We're drawing these circles that
connect to each other to express our ideas.
And I always had like carried this notion
in my head that Cypher would be a
really great language for infrastructure from like going
from whiteboard to code kind of. So
over time I had,
like five years ago, I had this initial
attempt to do something with this,
which was,
I called it OpsLang and it was like
a language that would compile down to Terraform
or Vulumi
and would, would let you express like infrastructure
stuff using Cypher. But that was,
I guess not, not that well
directed or the idea in my head wasn't,
you know, complete yet.
But then five years later I revisited,
you know, we were,
I was leading the DevOps team in Lemonade
and we were dealing with this
cluster that was having this, you know, it
was a big dev cluster of 300 something
nodes, ingress controllers were going wild and we
had a theory and why this was happening.
But just to prove our theory, it took,
like this,
I guess 10 line,
10 lines of bash code piped and parsed
and, you know, nest UCTL commands and
just to prove that this is what was
going on. And then we had to actually
to, to implement this as a solution. We
had to write API code and we had
to like
implement an operator.
And
it's, you know, it nagged me at that
time that I could express this one thing
with this whole thing could be expressed with
one line of Cypher. Like if I had
Cypher for Kubernetes,
I could do this with, with just one
line, you know.
And that's when I started to actually build
Cypher Netties
initially
as just a tool that I could use
to,
to show that this was the actual problem.
Right? So just doing the read parts, not
even
full CRUD, but just be able to be
able to do like match this pattern
and return something.
Match
any
deployment
that is exposed by a service that has
an ingress routing into it
where
some of these conditions, you know, match and
just return all of these. So where the
deployment has zero replicas, just return all of
these.
So the ability to do this on a
large cluster
with a single command
that would also take rate limiting into account.
Right? Because API
server would
like, this is an example where kubectl would
fail because
there's rate limiting and stuff. So, and also
being able to compose this
ad hoc response
with
only
very specific fields from different resource kinds together.
So this was the
thing I started working on a year and
a half ago, almost a year and a
half ago.
This is what it started out from just
being able to do match this pattern and
return
these elements and these fields. And then I
found it so useful and it very quickly
became
an important tool in my belt, you know,
that I was using daily. So I just
kept extending it. And first I added
a match set to be able to update
like patch resources
and then came delete and then create. And
then I started improving the
language and adding more and more language features,
adding aggregation functions.
Yeah. And it's like in continuous motion ever
since, you know, every, every time
somebody and, well, first it was just me,
but then all of a sudden a community
started forming around this. I think somewhere around
last September,
it took me a year, I think, to
go from zero GitHub stars to 50. And
then in twenty four hours, it went from
50 to a hundred and then twenty four
hours more, it was 100 to 200
and then it built up to 500.
And then
in forty eight hours more, suddenly I was
on the front page of hacker news and
forty eight hours more, went from 500 to
a thousand. And now I'm all of a
sudden I'm counting and I'm counting my stars
in hundreds, you know, and not in singles
anymore. It's yeah. So, so a small community
started to form around this,
which is, which is crazy to me because
I kind of thought this was super niche
and I was going to develop in the
public and put it out there anyway. But
I thought if I find 10 people in
the world who are Cypher fans who work
with Kubernetes a lot, it would be cool.
You know, we could have a small community
and yeah, all of a sudden I have
users from all over the world, people working
in large environments,
large clusters,
which is where my problems were, you know,
and I find that these exact kind of
users
find,
you know, they get they get the value
from this tool and it's it's just incredible.
Yeah. There's there's a lot to unpack there,
but you're completely right.
I'll say first, you're like a thousand stars
away from VC funding. Right? So you just
gotta keep that hockey stick growth going. But
I think using
Cypher and, you know, a graph based query
language is such a clever move. Right? I
spend a lot of my time running kubectl
commands.
And because we have so many disparate resources
that are interconnected,
but, you know, not like a real graph,
you end up running one command here, getting
an output, run another command. At some point,
you start writing bash scripts. I'm now at
the stage where I've got TypeScript scripts, TypeScript
scripts,
where I'm, you know, hitting the Kube control
API server, parsing some JSON, running it through
a function, and it's a lot of work.
And the reason it's a lot of work
is because it's just not the right approach.
And then the minute I seen Cypher Netties,
I was like, oh,
you know, I've just been looking at the
problem the wrong way. When you flip it
on its head and actually use a language
that is built to do this kind of
graph traversal
Yes. Things start to click. And that was,
like, the the moment I was just like,
okay. Right. We need to we need to
show people this project. So I was very
excited.
Yeah. Thank you. Yeah. I think you you
you hit the spot. Like, this is the
exact problem that this is solving and
yeah. So thanks for thank you so much
for appreciating and inviting me to be on
the show.
Okay. Cool.
Well, I mean, I don't need to ask
you what the name means. I think that's
pretty self explanatory.
But I do think maybe we should, you
know, share a screen.
Yep. Do some examples, give people an idea
of how to get started, and then hopefully
we can explore some of those more difficult
use cases. I'm definitely curious to see what
you have been doing with CypherNet is beyond
what I think I would end up doing
with CypherNet. Yeah. Yeah.
Definitely. Pushes over here.
Now we see your terminal.
Yeah. Just take it away, and I'll throw
loads of questions at you as we go.
Sounds good. Okay. So let's just fire it
up. And so Cypher NetEase, the CLI actually
contains
a few applications,
but I'll start from the one
that I, that I started from, which is
a Cypher NetEase shell. It's just an interactive
shell that lets you write,
evaluate Cypher queries or Cypher Native queries,
right, in your terminal.
And so
this is the
very minimal example, right, of doing a match
return statement is I would match,
and then I would draw this pattern, right.
This,
graph node,
node graph pattern, and inside each node would
be a variable name.
D,
and
let's say
a Kubernetes kind in Cypher, this is called
the label,
but
Cypher Niddies, we use labels to denote resource
kinds, right? So match all deployments
that are
exposed by
services
and then return,
the
number of replicas in each deployment
and
the cluster IP of each service. Right.
And then this would return
a list of all deployments
and replicas.
Right?
And
their respective services
and cluster IPs.
And
I could refine this query further by adding
a where clause and say where the spec
replicas
is
large, let's say larger than two, greater than
two. And then I would only get back
billing service where I have
three rep,
And
this thing right here, this little arrow
is, is where all the magic happens, right?
This is the magic of CypherDesk. It's understanding
the connections
between resource kinds and
this chain
of,
so we're not limited to only two resource
kinds. Of course we could match,
that's for example, config maps,
all the config maps that are being used
by pods,
that belong in a replica sets
that belong in a deployment,
you know, and just,
return the
data from this config map and the P
let's say the phase of the pod
and the
name of the replica sets and a number
of replicas
and
the deployment. Right. And I would get this,
all the data, you know, from four different
resource kinds,
aggregated
in one
custom payload.
Yeah. Before you take anything else.
Mhmm. We we we need to take a
moment. Right? Because if there's anyone that's watching
that hasn't already sold on Cybernetics,
what the fuck is wrong with you? Right?
Because this is
like, it's the devil is in the details
here. There was just so much that I
think we need we're gonna have to go
over some of this. Right? But Yep. The
autocomplete,
I I wasn't expecting that. That was wonderful.
The relationship
inference is very cool. We could talk about
how you're doing that. I'm very curious. But
the thing that caught my eye right from
the very, very start is that when you
kicked off the CypherNet shell,
it actually analyzed the schema of the cluster
to build these types. Right? And when you
scroll up, there was just two log lines
that stood out as really, really awesome.
Now my first question was gonna be I'm
assuming the answer is a yes. Right? But
you're not just working with the core v
one APIs. I'm assuming it works with CRDs
within the cluster. It would work with your
CRDs, no problem, and it can even add
custom relationships.
So the relationship engine, yeah, that was, this
is something that's always in continuous right?
In the beginning, everything was hard coded. I
just had a list of,
resources or rules between two kinds
and each rule needs to contain
one or more criterions
for the, for the resources to match. So
for example,
a rule between,
replica sets and
deployments would be of course the owner reference,
from the metadata of the,
replica set needs to match the metadata name
on field on the deployment. And
so that's one rule between replica sets and
deployments. And I just had,
like, I guess a hundred or
so
hard coded rules.
For the first year or so, I want
to say of Cypher Native's development, this entire
relationship engine was just,
hard coded. Same goes for auto completion, like
resource specs.
I just asked an AI to generate a
bulk of, you know, just a huge
list of, for each resource guide in the
core resources
and in the V1 groups, you know, just
list
as many
adjacent paths as possible for each one. And
for a long time it was hard coded.
And I think it was around last September
that
I
kind of realized, okay, this is becoming a
serious thing. And people already started to ask,
you know, in the community and passing,
well, not really passing criticism, but asking me,
how did you do this? And I would
say, yeah, this is hard coded right now.
And eventually I'll get to do this. And,
so
once more people started actually,
not just using it but having their eyes
on the code, you know, when I realized,
okay, people are actually looking at this, better
save my reputation and
do something serious here. So
I started
doing
this thing where, where, when you connect to
the, when you launch Cypher Natives either into
the shell or the web client, which we'll
look into in a bit,
then it downloads
the open API schema from the,
from the cluster.
It generates all the auto completion,
specs for all the resource kinds that the
service supports
and no more hard coded auto completion anymore.
And then it starts scanning.
Well, it does a few things. So a
few of the, of those relationships are still
hard coded. This is, you know, this is
always a work in progress. I like to
say this is, yeah, right. This is continuous,
but something,
I think the most dramatic thing that I
did that I started doing there was just
looking up after I generated this list for
auto completion, right. I started going through field
names and then wherever I see a field
that ends with either ref
or
key ref or name,
then I would look
behind
that, you know, key ref or ref or
name. I would look at the word behind
that.
And I would look in the, in the
GVR
cache that I built from the open API
spec. If there's an actual resource kind
that matches this name. And if there is,
then I would just create this relationship. So
you could,
you can add a CRD
that has a field called deployment name
and Cypher Natives would automatically detect the relationship
between deployments and your,
in your CRD.
Yeah. I mean, like I said, the devil's
in the details here because in Kubernetes land,
there's no concept of relationships whatsoever. It's all
very loose definition.
I mean Yeah.
So so again, to me, this was if
I go back to that moment where I
was looking at all the API code that
we wrote and the operator that we were
implementing, and I thought to myself, this needs
to be internal.
Like Kubernetes needs to expose,
like to hold a graph model internally
and just have this language available to us.
Like I shouldn't be writing these
lines or 2,000
lines of operator code that everybody's writing. It's
always the same code. Like the actual business
logic inside most of these custom Kubernetes controllers,
especially the ones handling,
only handling internal resources,
it's not much. Like most of the code
is what everybody else is writing, all the
SKU builder
gen controller stuff.
So
to me, this was like a moment where
I figured I'm going to build the system
that can take these one liners, like these
Cypher one liners and
just run them continuously like an operator or
even listen to events.
And
yeah, so this is,
this was where I
came up with the idea for
actually building a mini operator framework
around this.
Yeah.
Are we back?
Hey. Hey. I'm not sure if I'm out
or if David is.
Let me stop my screen share.
We'll see.
Hey.
Well, I guess David is out, but I
might as well continue
demoing this.
So let me show off a few cool
other examples for stuff I use,
cipher nettings on the daily with,
which is not,
only match return. Like let's, let's look at
how this goes beyond the,
just doing read operations.
So,
let's say I wanted to
look at all pods.
Am I back? Yeah. You are.
Wanna be sure if you're Sorry. Yeah.
My Wi Fi decided that it's done for
the day, and I'm now tethering.
So thank you for I I don't know.
Maybe you sang a song or you've just
been showing off your No. Would kill something.
Yeah. I realized you dropped, and then I
figured, yeah, let's let's carry this thing.
But you joined right when I did. So,
okay.
All right. So,
so maybe I'll show, I'll show something beyond
the, like match return stuff. So for example,
this is something very common, right? That I
see people doing on the daily where,
and this is the example, actually the first
example I have on my readme, right. Which
is something a lot of people do, which
is like to match all pods where the,
where the status,
phase
of the pod isn't
running,
right. And then delete the pod,
right. Faulty service. I had one, I had
one let's,
I could show
match all pods and return the piece
status,
phase.
Right. And I can see, I have all
these pods.
This is running, this one's running and
faulty services. Well, it's, it's pending right now.
Right.
So if I run this query,
right.
It'll just delete the one
or,
or yeah. Or if I ask it to,
only match the ones that are running right.
And
set
their,
say
metadata,
annotations
foo equals bar. Right?
And,
what did I do wrong here? So rejected
due to an error in my
request. Oh,
Well, this isn't,
this isn't nice,
but,
I'll give another example. So let's match,
all deployments
where
the spec,
replicas
is higher than two,
return the metadata
name,
right? It's billing service. So let's ask it
to set the spec
replicas
to,
I don't know, one
or
four,
and it will patch
billing service. And then if I ask it
to,
return,
the number of replicas again,
I can see that patched up to four
because,
Similarly,
yeah, similarly, I could ask it to, you
know, use a, use a
complex
pattern here, like, like I showed before with
four or five or however many resource kinds
where with
one or more conditions in the where clause
and yeah, it'll just know how to patch
all of them.
Yeah, it's such a powerful
model.
Limits of what you could do with this
are pretty cool. I I like where it
goes, and it just simplifies a lot of
those tedious kubectl commands and piping through j
q and all this other stuff. Right? This
this is just a really elegant way of
working with it. And, again, it's because you've
approached it without looking at the existing query
methods and just came at it from a
different angle, which I think works really well.
And did you, during my absence, handle the
question from Alejandro?
I did not. Did not. I did not
realize it was
So Alejandro
is curious if he can use this from
Go. So I guess Yeah. Maybe you could
share some information on and as as CypherKnight
is written in Go, can people use it
as a library? What are they used?
Definitely.
So this, I think is a good is
maybe a good segue for like my
vision for this generally. Right? Or the why
I'm doing this, writing this shell. We'll look
in a minute, we'll look at the web
client and the operator framework that I built
around cybernetics.
So
my idea for this is that this is
a really great language and I just want
this to be a language for Kubernetes that's
available to any project out there. The latest
release that we did for Cypher NetEase v15,
which
was released just last week was very
much around
this, around the effort of
separating the language, like creating a clean interface
between the language and the actual Kubernetes provider.
So,
when you,
integrate this into Go,
you can use, so Syphonetics includes this package,
called core
and a provider called API
server,
which is a provider for running Kubernetes queries
against the API server of your cluster.
And you can just include this package.
And if your existing project is already a
Kubernetes project and you just want to,
include Cypher Netties,
support, then you can bring your own Kubernetes
client into Cypher Netties and they'll use that.
You can also,
just have the Cypher Natives core package spun
up its own,
set of like Kubernetes dynamic client and, and,
and,
discovery clients.
But additionally,
like, as I said, the interface is very
clean,
like cleanly separates the language from actually Kubernetes.
So even products that don't use Kubernetes,
like ones for big, larger observability
product
that use, I know, like reflect etcd into
Postgres or elastic search or something like that.
Then you can also implement a new provider
on top of our API server provider and
just change the GET requests, for example, to
read them from
Postgres or Elasticsearch or your custom backend. Right.
And all of these,
applications
that I built, the operator framework, the shell,
the web, I see them as proof of
concept, right? That the language has merit because
almost everybody that I show them this,
ask me something like, oh, so how can
I use this for alerts? Right? How can
I create metrics with this? Oh, this would
be great for showing me
best practices. Like where do I have misconfigurations
and stuff? So I think all of these
are great applicable
ideas
for cipher natives. And I just want the
the language to be out there, for other
go projects to be able to integrate and
build awesome stuff around.
Yeah. I mean, I think once you have,
I'm assuming I know. I've I've tried not
to make assumptions on behalf of other people.
Right? For me personally, I can see myself
coming up with a whole bunch of health
checks and safety queries that I wanna run
regularly against my cluster that do identify anomalies.
Now, of course, I've got monitoring and other
stuff. Right?
But those are read only and so require
manual intervention or other tooling. What I like
about the Cypher NetEase approach is that I
can actually build down some rather
well, I mean, you can start off with
primitive reconciliation where required, you know, opt in
the replicas if you need to, if things
are getting too slow.
But also I could I see a situation
where I have a runbook, like a Jupyter
Notebook that runs a various of these queries
and provides like a single pane of glass
into the cluster for people that, you know,
just aren't that clear of Kubernetes. Like, you
know, one of That would be incredible. Knowledge
as much as possible. Right?
Because, again, we can't expect everyone on the
team to be able to drop one into
a terminal, run 50 queries just to say,
is my cluster healthy? And, again, I know
people are screaming at me going, well, have
Grafana and have all these tools and spend
money here and then do all that. That.
Sometimes you just need to get into the
weeds of things. And I think there's a
time and a place. And I do have
monitoring, but sometimes I think I know better
than the monitoring, which is maybe a little
bit of a hubris. However,
does I think what you're everything you said
there is perfect as well. It's like, you
know, you proved the method in the language,
and I think the bounds of what you
could build on top of this and tools
and interfaces,
user interface, all of this is really exciting,
and I can't wait to see some more.
Before
we take a look at operators and and
web stuff, like, what else does the CLI
do? What else is available to people? Is
it just a shell or is there something
else?
So the shell is also
it also includes a web client and you
can actually also deploy
the operator, but that's more for testing and
dev work. The operator
also exists on
artifact hub, of course.
But,
so the shell,
Cypher,
Kubernetes, it has the
shell
application that we just saw. You can also
run single queries. So like Cypher Natives query
something.
I can just take this into Bash scripts.
Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. For CI,
manage p pod,
return
p. Right?
Can those queries be chained? Like, if I
do a match, find all pods, and I
wanna chain those results to another query, is
that something we can do with Cypher?
So not yet. Well, with actual Cypher, yes.
With Cypher Nitties, not yet. This is definitely
on the roadmap, but, but not yet.
And yeah, so besides
shell and query, which is what I started
off with, you know, and I was developing
the shell, adding auto completion, coloring, all of
this,
at one point,
you know,
I added,
a friend told me what, well, why won't
this draw graphs? Right. And I thought about
it and I kind of like in my
mind, went over it and I said, yeah,
I mean, I do collect all this info
and I have the relationship info. I can
just create a list of nodes and graphs
and just draw it. So I started out
by adding this
option in the, in the shell first, you
know, it was,
so this disabled
graph output, it's true by default, but if
you,
just run the backslash G
it'll start,
drawing graphs for everything to match. So let's
do this one again.
So match the configured maps into pods, into
record sets, into deployments and just return all
of this and it'll,
Oh no. So I have, I have an
issue here. I'm going to have to fix
this afterwards.
I'm sorry about that, but let's, but let's
actually look at this in the web, right?
Let's look at this in the web client.
So,
it'll send me into a local host 8080,
And then
let's,
let's see what do I have here. Oh,
yeah. I have I have pretty much the
same query here in in history. So is
that the query history from the interactive shell
as well? Is it Not from the shell.
This one actually stays in local storage in
the browser, but just so happens that I
have the same query because I was demoing,
before. So this is an example I like
to give, right? So,
you can see that it's, it gives us
a nice little graph representation
of,
of the deployment that goes into the replica
sets and going, goes into the pod and
the,
config map and just hovering over one would,
would narrow down the results that we see
on the, on the lessons. I mean, looks
familiar. This is the actual Neo4j
interface. So I
was paying tribute, you know, I was paying
tribute to the, to the,
program that got me hooked on Cypher, you
know, this is,
so let's see, imagine deployments and services and
return DS and,
here are all the deployments and services. And
let's say, I want to also see the,
the pods
and
replica sets, right.
The
P
yeah. And
just get all of these back and this
lets me kinda,
you know, focus
and
narrow down the results here.
And I added little options of
view underneath as Jason or YAML and filter
out the managed fields
that
usually nobody wants to look at and a
bunch of other options that kind of made
this my new daily driver.
I want to say I was doing this
more
kind of for PR reasons because I thought
it looked sexy and, you know, I'll put
the video out there and which it did,
you know, it brought, definitely brought more attention
to Cypher Nadees, but I actually found myself
using this more
than the interactive shell and just starting to
use the web interface, which is pretty cool.
So, so much so that I didn't notice
that the graph functionality
broke in the shell.
Like it did just now in the demo.
So I'm gonna run and fix that right
after our session.
Okay. Nice.
So what about a situation
where
it's unable to determine
a relationship?
Is it possible with the query language to
say that these are related on these fields
with this discriminator of some way like? Yes.
Yes.
Yes. So this is, this was something that
the community was asking for and I just
ended,
I just added at one point you can
see here that it says I added, it
found 79
internal relationship and one custom. So the custom
relationships you can put in your,
dot cipher Nidhi's,
relationships.
And if we look at that, that would
be a way to describe a relationship between,
for example, pods and deployments. Right.
So
a deployment owns a pod
if, and this is the criteria and it
only has a single criterion.
If the field
metadata
name
of the pod
contains
the metadata name of the deployment.
So just a demo,
you know,
pretty, you know,
optimistic
relationship
that I added just for, you know, testing
purposes or demo purposes right now. But let's
assume a deployment owns a pod, right? If
the, if the
name of the pod contains the name of
the deployment, right? So if it's a user's
service is the name of the deployment,
then it makes sense that user service,
something
is related to that. So if I'll just
launch back into the show and match,
the deployments
that are connected to pods and return
the
spec replicas again
and the p status
status
phase.
Yeah.
So I get all of these.
Okay. I'm gonna I don't wanna put you
on a spot, so if this is too
tricky, we can follow-up later on this. Right?
But let's do a match query and find
all service accounts.
Let's start query
that'll find all service accounts. Alright. So let's
say s a
find all service
accounts. Right?
Return
as a,
whatever.
Yeah. Meditator. Name.
All right. Yeah. The name name is by
the way, is always returned by default, you
know, like a special name field, but yeah,
we can do this and it'll return the
name twice. So this is the only service
account I have right here. It's default one.
Okay. So can we now request the pods
that are using this service account?
Let's
see. Let's see. I'm gonna assume the inference
doesn't detect us. I was wondering if we
could do it manually.
And then there's the hard
mode as well. We we can try. We
can try. Let's see. So status phase.
Oh, it actually detected that all of these
are using the the default. And this is
not something I hard code service accounts into
pods. Definitely not. So probably pod
has
a service
account name on it. Yes. So just because
it ends with the word name,
then it looked up what's behind name, what
came before name and it was service account
and it realized,
oh, there is a GVR,
you know, called service accounts. So that matches
service accounts. So I would create the connection
between these two. And yeah, it just worked.
Let's let's try the hard mode question because
now I'm I'm feeling a bit more confident
that this might work. Alright. Alright. Let's find
service It surprised me too. You know? Let's
find service accounts and rule rule bindings.
Let's see. So service accounts
We may have to do this in the
cube system namespace.
Let's
see. Let's do that. Let's do that. Let's
go to cube system and
match
all,
service accounts
that connect into a role bindings.
Yeah.
Role binding metadata name. Yours whole thing.
Resource.
It's scan. So yeah. No. No. Relationship not
found. Yeah. It didn't detect the relationship between
those two.
Yeah. So we could probably write a custom
relationship to do that. And but let's let's
skip a step because I I I want
us to do a couple of, oh, I
don't know, like, maybe talk about the operator
before we finish. Right? But Okay. What I
actually want you to do is stay okay.
There's been a service accounts that have some
sort of role bindings, and then really what
I wanted to do is filter them on
the role bindings where they have certain permissions.
So let's just do the query of role
binders to see if we can find one
that has permission to create pods.
Mhmm. Yeah. I'm not I'm not sure if
I have one in this cluster, but let's
see. So That's why I said go to
cube system. So I'm assuming we'll be able
to work with system masters.
Mhmm. Mhmm. Let's let's first look at what
this returns. Right?
So,
well, we have a few role bindings. Right?
Let's Oh, you'll need to get the role
of that.
Mhmm.
So if you can then build the relationship
to the role or cluster role.
I don't know. Maybe that won't exist either,
but we can try. Let's see.
Yeah. So this works out of the box.
Row bindings into roles works. Yeah.
Mhmm. Okay. So can we see the whole
rule object?
Yeah. You just return r. Yeah. Yeah.
There we go. So now we've got access
to the rules
where we could create on
verbs create pods.
So rules,
verbs Our secrets secrets watch. Let's just keep
it simple for now. Right?
Mhmm.
So is that something we can query? So
we're looking for any role that has or
any role of a role binding that has
the ability to execute secrets
watch.
So where
role
Roles. Let's say,
Rules.
Rules. Sorry.
Yeah.
Any. Right?
Verbs.
And we're looking for contains
watch.
Yeah. Contains
This is so cool. It
was expecting a number in an array index
and it got a star. It's supposed to
take a star as well. I'll check why
this didn't work, but, yeah, if I just
change it to zero, then, yeah, it detects
lot of these.
That is very, very interesting.
I mean, these are some of the more
difficult queries that I run against my clusters
on a regular basis, which is, you know,
trying to understand the security posture, who has
access, who has over permissions. And,
again, I do know there are tools I
can go pay for for this than some
open source tools, but sometimes I just like
to run some queries. Like, this I can't
believe how many this is like 80 characters
at most, and I'm getting a lot of
information back. To me, that is just
that is wonderful.
I mean, I could not be happy to.
Yeah.
This is what turned it very quickly into
a daily driver for me. You know, even
just the most simple stuff you can think
of just changing
a value
in a, in a Helm chart, right. And
then applying this chart.
And then I want to see the three
different resources that it changed and effect that
it had on specific fields, you know, just,
just doing this day to day, very basic
stuff, turn Cypher Nitties into a daily driver.
Like I can't do without this on the,
on the day for me, and I'm definitely
gonna fix the star not working here.
We try it just with the open close
squares. Would that work?
So just remove the zero?
No.
No, no. It's a, it's supposed to take
a, yeah, this is expected number and actually
I'm, yeah. So this is a regression because
I remember taking stars as well, but never
mind though. We'll we'll get this working.
There's gonna be a patch by the end
of the day for this. That will take
stars as well.
Alright.
Edward Hart, I've already popped a comment on
the screen, but he's really loving the look
of this.
And hi, Alejandro is asking, is this like
having a sequel there on top of Kubernetes?
I mean, yeah. It is So there's
there's prior
work, you know, there's, there's been other projects
that did this with SQL,
but
while SQL,
I think is a great choice for a
query language because everybody knows SQL and almost
nobody in the world
knows Cypher.
Well, most people from the data realm, right,
they know Cypher,
but not so much, not so many people
in operations and DevOps.
But
I think SQL,
fundamentally
for doing this kind of stuff, just having
to write joins,
you know, it's, to me it felt so
off.
I, I, it didn't even, you know, cross
my mind. It was,
I need Cypher for Kubernetes.
This was a, like a given for me.
So I did of course look into all
the projects that tried to do this before
me and all of them used SQL.
And I think Cypher is just a better
choice for this, you know, because I think
this little arrow, being able to do this,
you know, this is so powerful. There's so
much that that's happening behind these two characters.
That to me feels like magic, you know?
Yeah. Again, it's the
user experience and the ergonomics, right? You're working
with graph data, you need a language that
can understand and take away some of the
imperative nature. SQL with all these joins and
extra things like that,
it is not pleasant for this time of
structured data. So Yes. You know, I think
it's inside it's just an absolute brilliant project.
I mean, I'm gonna say this is the
coolest Kubernetes project I have seen this year.
And by this year, mean, in last ten
days. Not the last ten days, the last
twelve months. This is the coolest thing. I'm
humbled. Thank you so much for taking that.
Alright. You wanna take a look at the
operator real quick? So this is
going back, going back to the problem that
started it all. Right. I told you before
I was heading the,
DevOps, the infrastructure division in Lemonade,
and we had this big dev cluster, 300
something nodes, right? And these are all dev
environments.
So every night the cluster kind of goes
to sleep, right? And the way we, because
devs don't work at night and the way
we put it to sleep is we scale
down all the deployments.
And then over time we started noticing the
ingress controller growing wild
because
the,
let me boot up the shell and because,
if you looked at the deployments and
services that they connect to
and
exposed by ingresses,
right,
return the spec replicas
and return the S cluster
AP and the I
spec
ingress
class name,
right? So,
yeah, if you looked at these over time
NGINX Ingress started to grow
bonkers because
what we realized or what we were theorizing,
right, was that
there were missing endpoints because some of these
people were not bringing their environments back online,
right?
Either because they left the company or they
don't need the environment anymore,
or they went on vacation and so on
and so forth. Right. But we kept on
having a growing number of deployments
that actually had zero replicas.
And that caused the validation
webhooks of NGINX ingress to crash
over time in a larger cluster. You know,
the more missing end points it had, the
more CPU it was burning every time it
was doing config reloads.
And then our ingresses started failing altogether.
Right. So my thought was
we, all we need to do is find
all these deployments
that have zero replicas,
right? Like match.
So
do this thing right where
these spec replicas
equals zero.
And then instead of returning something set,
spec
ingress class name to
inactive,
right. Or something just
make, have the ingress control or not select.
Right.
And then, and then do the, and then
on the flip side, change it to active
if it has more than zero revenue. Right.
So that
was the initial idea that where I thought
I could express this whole thing in one
line of Cypher. It was this,
right?
So after almost a year of developing Cypher
Niddies and doing the shell and the shell
started to feel kind of mature,
that's where I said, okay, now I'm going
to build a mini operator framework around this.
And
so in my mind, I wish right. That
Kubernetes
hold held this internally and to express
decision making
like this in Kubernetes,
we can, we can express it with one
line.
Like ideally in my mind, Kubernetes would have
this custom resource where I can tell it,
or this is at least how I imagined
it. Let's go to a project Cyphernes
operator.
I have a
nice little sample here.
So dynamic operator, ingress activator,
right?
Where
on update,
right? It watches deployments.
This is a concept I kind of
invented for this, which is like a continuous
query or I called it a dynamic operator.
Right?
So this is a way to spawn
these many dynamic operators on the fly
and just tell them, Hey,
watch all the deployments
in the default namespace.
And when there's an update
match the deployment with
this
name, right. That connects to a service connects
to an ingress where the spec replicas is
zero would change the ingress class name to
inactive.
If it, and then run another query
where if it's larger than zero, change it
to active. So just run these two queries
whenever,
against
a certain deployment, whenever this deployment changes.
Right.
So let's look at this in action. If
I go to,
helm,
rights and let's do helm install,
install this,
install it into the,
into the cluster.
Let me open up the siphonase shell here.
Siphonase
shell.
And let's look again at
these, right?
So I have public API with one replica
and the
ingress class name is active here, right?
So let me apply
from the,
from that same,
or let's look at it before. Oh, we
just did actually. So let me apply this
dynamic operator, right? So apply,
test.
If you go dash f. Oh, yeah. Yeah.
Dash f. Test.
Oh, yeah.
Apply
test
E2E samples
and apply this,
dynamic operator Ingress activator
dynamic operator, right? So this is now applied
to the cluster. The Cypher Nades operator,
just detected it and it's, it created
this dynamic operator, right? It set up the
watcher for deployments
and whenever a deployment changes, it's just going
to run these two queries. So,
again, if I look at this, this is
public API with,
right. And then let's take this and say,
set
the
spec
replicas,
change this to zero.
Right.
So it patched it. And now if I
do the lookup again, I can see that
the dynamic operator changed it to inactive
and
back again,
set it to something else, one or two,
whatever,
and match it again, it'll set it to
active.
Nice. Very, very cool. Yeah. So this was
one year after I started working on it
and it finally
solved
the problem
that, you know, that sparked the idea initially.
That's very, very cool. I like that dynamic
operator thing. I mean, that looks back to
what I was saying earlier. I'd love to
be able to run things on a cadence
and do some debugging and health checking, and
it's already exists with the operator. So now
we just need to build the Jupyter Notebook
kernel and we'll be we'll be happy. So
That sounds incredible. It sounds incredible. I I
would love that. Something that popped into my
head is that, you know, we've been running
match statements against a single namespace. We've seen
how to switch namespace. Can we query the
entire cluster? Yes, definitely can.
In the shell, if I do,
namespace all, it'll go into this like namespaces
mode and then yeah, we can, we can
match
namespaces,
which have a
special relationship with,
with the rest of the,
so that's returned the
name of all the namespaces and the P
metadata name. And,
we can see all the
names,
all the different namespaces and the parts that
belong in them. And we can do the
same thing for nodes and yeah.
More,
even more than that,
switch back to default, even more than that,
it supports multi context queries.
I can do something like in,
so I have two
contexts here, right? Kind, kind and kind, kind
prods. So match
all the deployments into replica sets into pods
in both of these contexts.
Right.
And so
it'll tell me that in
kind kind prod, I have auth service with
one replica and the kind kind prod P
is, you know, it's just this, and this
is the replica sets that I have in
Kankind prod.
And this is from this context. From Kankind,
it has D.
So it even does like multi namespace, multi
cluster, what have you.
Honestly, I feel like just flipping my table
and storming off because it should not be
this cool. I mean
That's awesome. Again,
I mean, I just can't imagine people watching
this and not finding this really exciting for
change in the way they interact with Kubernetes
clusters. So
is there anything else you want to show
us before we jump back and ask a
few more questions?
No. I think this is about it.
Yeah. That's it. I just showed you these,
like, four amazing things, but, you know, until
next time. So let let's focus on you
people on this now.
It's a very good point from what I
can see? Right? Like, I don't see a
reason why people can't start using and adopting
this today. What do you see for the
future of Kubernetes? Where are you going? What's
on the roadmap?
Yeah.
So,
two parallel lines is,
first of all, there's a community building up
around this thing and people are asking for
features.
People want to see, want to have a
way to query metrics,
right. And set up alerts around this. So
I'm starting to think like, what would the
language around this would look like? You know,
watch something for return CPU.
We didn't even look into actually in the
demo now we didn't even look into aggregation
functions. And,
so you're able to aggregate,
CPU usage and memory usage and a bunch
of really cool stuff that this already does.
And I want to be able to,
give away to the users because this is
highly requested in community to query these metrics
over time and then do this decision making
like we saw in the operator based off.
So kind of like setting up alerts or
setting up, you know, different processes that happen,
using metrics. That's one thing. And I want
to keep extending the language
with more Cypher features.
So something that this doesn't yet do and
I really wanted to do is to be
able to also
use
patterns,
use ASCII art patterns inside where statements and
inside the lead statements.
So,
match,
all the config maps
where not config map connects to pod,
return this config map name. So return all
the names of config maps that are not
being used by any, by any pod. Right.
So,
this is, an extension of the language, which
would bring it, you know, more on par
with Cypher,
that I'm going to be diving into in
the near
or medium future, I guess.
But more long term,
like I said in the beginning, my vision
for this is not
to have a VC backed
product that I'm building around this. I want
this to be,
standardized
and I want this language to be available
ideally,
you know, and I know how much politics
is involved, but ideally just, you know, internally
held by Kubernetes and
because I don't see this as replacing
anything,
right? I see this as an extension to
like a missing tool
because this is how I experienced it. It's
a missing tool for seasoned Kubernetes professionals who've
been doing this for a long time. They
know the anatomy of their resources.
They know,
yeah. And they just need a, like they,
they end up writing all these long shell,
like write once read, never, you know,
shell,
one liners that pipe and parse hell.
I call this, you know, nested
cube control commands.
And
ideally this is what I want for this,
you know, to just
be available and to be standardized and to
become like another tool that's available to us
because I really feel like it's a missing,
and I don't think I'm the first one
who feels like it's a missing tool because
there's so much prior art of
projects that tried to like create a
SQL based query language for Kubernetes.
But I think this has a lot of
merit and it'll work for a lot of
people. And I actually think it's worth
picking up the new syntax because it puts
so much power in your hands and and
it's actually enjoyable too, you know.
So far, everything you've shown us has shown
how to take Cypher Netties and look inwards
with the cluster. Are there any plans to
then broaden the scope of that? I'm thinking
send web hooks and Slack notifications.
Like,
has there been any thoughts there? Like, it,
or is this fresh?
So there's been
some thoughts around this. I'm still not sure
yet how this is going to work out.
Because again, I want my fork, my focus
to be more and more around,
language feature development and less around, you know,
developing applications for this. But yeah, I would
love
like Cypher has this really cool notation for
using plugins,
using ampersand where you can tell it to
just like ampersand something, it'll shoot out an
external Java function.
And I think something like this would be
really cool, you know, so that if you
have a, like maybe a plugin system where
if you have this plugin installed,
where your Cypher Net is,
binary is or whatever,
then you can also ask it to like,
query some metrics over time
and
return an ampersand Slack something,
you know, they'll send a Slack message or
what have you. So I have, I have
some ideas, you know, brewing around this.
It's not yet, you know,
per se on the road map, but, yeah,
it's definitely definitely on my mind.
Awesome.
I mean, that was the the one thing
I thought would be really cool to build
on top of this. And I think a
plug in system would be a good way
to do it, especially if there's, like, a
web assembly runtime in the cluster where we
can give it access to some components like
HTTP requests or whatever.
Then at that point, you're just seeing, you
know, build whatever you want,
and it saves you that middle step of,
you know, I I I could imagine if
I were to try and do something like
this tomorrow, I would probably just write have
create a a job. Right? And just spend
it off run once to shut back down.
But we could cut out that middle point
with a plug in system. So I think
that would be a very interesting and exciting
approach.
But other than that, I mean, I've just
gotta say I'm really impressed. I think this
is a fantastic language. I hope people, again,
are as passionate and interested in it as
I am just from sixty minutes of your
time. I'm like, wow. Like, this is even
cooler than I thought it was coming into
the session. And I was already excited, so
this is awesome. Thank you so much for
your time. Any Thank you. Final words before
we wrap this up for today? Go check
out CyberKnities.
Our community is growing and we're always listening
to our users. You know, this is top
of mind always, you know, open an issue,
tell us what you want to see Cypher
Natives doing next and it'll be the first
thing we'll jump on. You know, it's the
most important thing for us is listening to
how people are actually using it and then
just,
you know, following along.
Awesome.
Well, if you are in London for KubeCon
in a couple of months time, the beers
are on me and Hopefully. Look back in
your brain.
Looking forward. Thank thank you all for watching.
Thank you for joining me, and we'll catch
you all next time. Have a good day.
Hit subscribe so you won't miss a beat.
More livestream tutorials can't be beat. Keep coding,
keep learning. It's the Rawkode way. We'll catch
you next time. Have an awesome day.
Hit subscribe
time. Have an awesome day.